[موسيقى]
يوم استراحة فوق جبال البحر الأحمر ،
هذا هو أحد الجبال المفضلة لدي
، ويُطلق عليه سترة ، ويبدو نوعًا ما
أشبه بلهب يتصاعد من
حريق حتى وقت قريب بعيدًا عن المسار السياحي ،
هذه القمم هي مشهد مألوف
للمستكشف البريطاني بن هوفمان  الذين شرعوا
قبل خمس سنوات في إنشاء أول
مسار طويل المدى في البر الرئيسي لمصر ،
كانت جبال البحر الأحمر دائمًا
منطقة رئيسية حقًا لمصر ، أتت العديد من
الحضارات إلى هنا وشقوا
طرقًا عبر هذه الجبال من
الفراعنة إلى البطالمة إلى الرومان
ما فعلناه بمسار جبال البحر الأحمر
هو تحديد كل هذه
الطرق القديمة ووضعها معًا
بطريقة تخلق طريقًا للمشي لمسافات طويلة في العصر الحديث
، يعد المسار أحد حلقتين تم إعدادهما
في البلد
للانضمام إليه في هذه الرحلة وهما  زملائه
المتنزهين الذين
عملوا معه في عام 2015 لتطوير مسار مماثل
في شبه جزيرة سيناء تطوير
مسارات للسياحة هو شيء
أصبح الآن اتجاهًا
وينمو بسرعة كبيرة جدًا.  إن وجود أشخاص عاشوا
في هذه الأرض أو ربما مئات السنين
يضيف جانبًا مختلفًا
تمامًا لهذه التجربة من خلال
الانضمام إلى شبكة قديمة من
مجموعات السفر التجاري والصيد التي
يبلغ طولها مائة وسبعون كيلومترًا على طول المسار الذي
يعبر أرض ماسا كواحد من
مصر.  أكبر القبائل التي لعبت
دورًا فعالًا في تطوير
المسار ، فإن الممرات التي
يمتلكها المجتمع البدوي مائة بالمائة ،
لكن في عملية الإنشاء ، نسير
معًا آلاف الكيلومترات إذا كانت
الأهرامات نصبًا تذكاريًا للمصريين
كن أفضل
نصب تذكاري للبدو ، حيث إن المسافرين لدينا
بالنسبة لي ، لا توجد طريقة أفضل
لإظهار من هم البدو من السير
معهم في مسار أشيائي ، هذه
لحساسية الصدر ، كل شيء هنا
يخدم الغرض
[الموسيقى]
عندما يكون بشكل كامل  سيستغرق المسار التشغيلي
عشرة أيام لإكماله ، ومن خلال
تقديم الانغماس الثقافي الأصيل
مع الماسا ، فإنه سيفتح أحد
أقلها شهرة  مناطق وثقافات مصر
إلى نوع جديد من سياحة المغامرات ، فإن
جمالها هو أنه عندما تنشئ
مسارًا ، فإن هذا يخلق اقتصادًا صغيرًا
حول الفوائد التي يقدمها السكان المحليون في
تلك المنطقة المعينة لي ، يظهر لي
المكان الذي أتوا منه.  من
هم وكيف عاشوا وربما
هذا الجزء الذي يمكن أن يكون جزءًا من قصة
الذهاب في المستقبل أيضًا